thank you
welcome to effective teamwork in
healthcare thank you to all of the
participants who are joining us for more
than 75 countries around the world this
webinar is brought to you by Harvard
online
we're proud to share that one of our
panelists today Michaela kerosey was
recently named by thinkers 50 as one of
the 30 up and coming thinkers whose
ideals will make an important impact on
management thinking in the future
congratulations Michaela we're also
excited to share that Amy edmondson's
new book is coming out next month it's
called right kind of wrong the science
of failing well we like to start by
asking you what has been the most
successful failure in your career you
can sit with that question or you can
share a note in the chat
but before we get started we'll run
through a few housekeeping items all
participants will stay muted and the
chat function will be turned off for the
duration of the event
we will be answering questions
intermittently throughout the webinar
while we'll do our best to answer as
many questions as possible we will not
be able to answer all the questions we
encourage you to share your questions in
the Q a function at the bottom of your
screen
there you can you can submit your
questions and view questions from other
participants you can also upload
questions that resonate with you
at the end of this presentation we will
share a discount code and link to Amy
and Michaela's new course Innovations
and teamwork for healthcare
we're excited to introduce to you our
moderator and panelists for this event
Amy Edmondson
Michaela kerosey
and Derek bransby without further Ado
let's begin Derek the virtual floor is
yours
thank you Elaine and to our entire team
behind the scenes and again Welcome to
our webinar my name is Derek bransby and
I'm a third year doctoral student at
Harvard Business School where I study
how individuals groups and organizations
learn to collaborate innovate and
perform I'm also your moderator this
morning afternoon or evening wherever
you may be we are thrilled to have
participants from over 75 countries with
us today we're joined this afternoon by
two amazing panelists who I'm honored to
call colleagues and mentors Amy
Edmondson and Michaela kerosey
Amy is the Novartis professor of
leadership and management at Harvard
Business School she has pioneered the
concept of psychological safety for over
20 years and is the author of teaming
The Fearless organization and her latest
book the right kind of wrong the silence
the science Affairs failing well out
next week on September 5th
Michaela is an assistant professor of
management at the Harvard t.h Chan
School of Public Health she researches
how teams and organizations innovate
integrate and perform with a focus on
Health Care
Michaela has authored over 30
Publications on these topics and
designed the organization science for a
new era course at Harvard School of
Public Health
Michaela and Amy thank you for joining
us and we're delighted to have you today
our time together is split into two
parts first we'll discuss the challenges
facing Healthcare teams then in part two
we'll discuss teaming and how it might
help us address these challenges
both discussions will be followed by an
opportunity for questions from the
audience audience members if you haven't
already submitted your questions for Amy
and Michaela you can do so at any time
using the Q a function in our Zoom app
so let's get started
Michaela let's start with you telling us
a little bit about some of your earliest
experiences in healthcare and the
challenges facing Healthcare teams today
sure thanks Derek I started out in HIV
AIDS services and I think my story is
probably not all that unique for people
that wind up in healthcare I
I liked science and I wanted to do
something meaningful and improve human
health and then I realized on basically
day one that there are two parts to that
equation and pulling that off right one
is the one you expect
it's the technical expertise so whatever
it is if you're
a clinician it's the clinical medicine
if you're in population Health maybe
it's statistics you name it it's a
technical field but it's mastering that
that expertise domain and you know you
know that kind of going in right
and then
you kind of get blindsided by this other
side of it and that's when you realize
that it's not just the technical
expertise that you bring but it's the
teamwork across the technical expertise
that really makes it happen and I the
problem that I saw then and have
basically spent the last 20 years
working on is that in medicine we do so
much around that first issue the
Technical Training there's so much
training and credentialing and even the
on-the-job training is pretty good and
then on this second piece that basically
I don't I imagine I'm not alone and
who's ever on the line here who has
worked in healthcare delivery for more
than a minute probably knows this very
well uh the second part about how do you
do the teaming we get almost nothing no
training around no not a lot of support
around and that's that's a really
important Gap
um because we see so early on that it
really matters so that's what I have
been focused on
um really because I think that people
who work in healthcare deserve better
and and patience too
I know that's a story that resonates
with me and I'm sure many others with us
Amy you wrote the book on teaming and
have studied Healthcare settings
extensively in your work over the years
can you tell us about how the challenges
Michaela just described fit into a
larger picture of how teamwork is
different in healthcare than it is in
other settings
absolutely thank you yeah I um when I so
unlike the two of you my early work in
healthcare was as a researcher I was I
was a researcher in the field of
organizational behavior rather than as
one of the people actually working in
the space and so I was quite surprised
to discover probably almost as quickly
as Michaela discovered it
um how complex were the sort of
managerial and organizational size to
healthcare again all of you I'm sure
joining us today know this uh very well
but my part of my study my early study
was to study teams
that wasn't so easy like where are the
teams you know and I'd ask people tell
me about your team and they would say
well which team you know my rotation
team my unit team and I began to realize
that people weren't on stable formal
teams they were teaming they were
working in different teams at different
times of the day based on the work they
had to do so the you know the what I
learned in healthcare was that this was
a kind of a Bellwether or maybe an
extreme form of what other organizations
were facing where teamwork was getting
more and more complicated largely
because the uncertainty was high now
anytime uncertainty is high whether due
to the need for patient customization
because the inherent task variability or
other factors people need to team up
with each other to do the work but
without the luxury of stable
well-bounded you know well-practiced
teams so they do sort of teamwork on the
fly if you will they must learn as they
go from each other from what happens and
and make adjustments along the way it's
also of course as a 24th in in the
hospital setting at least to 24 7
operations compound the problem so being
on a stable team I learned is not the
reality for most people in healthcare by
the way I think it's no longer the
reality for people in in most business
organizations either but through the
best practices for fluid team which
which our course is really about and
which we'll talk more about today people
can achieve the benefits of teamwork
even without the luxury of stable teams
it's a great segue to our next question
for Michaela who recently wrote a
wonderful article aptly titled the
ambiguity of we and in this article
Michaela you found that there was
substantial variation in how Primary
Care teams composed of clinicians and
staff to find their team
what do your findings tell us about the
challenges that Healthcare teams face
what's interesting in listening to what
Amy was just saying in many ways the
first big Insight of that paper is is
putting some numbers and some real
evidence to this point that Amy just
made observing it when you first went
into to do research on Healthcare teams
which is that these
um the degree of instability in the
teams is so high and what we found even
in Primary Care environments where it's
probably a bit more stable than it is in
some other more acute Healthcare
environments even in that environment we
saw
um a lot of fluidity or shifting team
membership and how people describe their
teams
um and what was so striking about the
findings from that study
um was that the the way people saw their
teams varied dramatically in such a
messy teamwork context
so you take two doctors practicing in
the same Primary Care Clinic and one
doctor if you ask who's on your care
team day in and day out they might list
two other roles that they work with
and then the doctor
with their office just down the hall
would list 15 different roles
and the implication the first point of
that paper that it's a bit of a wonky
point but it really matters because it's
a measurement problem but it's also a
meaning problem
if we don't know who we're talking about
and what we're talking about when we
talk about teamwork it's really hard to
improve it and make it better because
we're all talking about different things
so so one point there is just this real
need to get much sharper in how we talk
about teamwork and how we measure it uh
there's a lot of money and time spent at
least in the US and those of you from
other countries can tell me what it's
like in your countries but in the US
almost every single Medical Group and
Hospital in the country is collecting
data about teams and our study would
suggest that when people fill out those
questions on surveys they're actually
talking about very different things
and so I think that's exciting because
in the next 10 years we are going to get
a lot better and sharper about how we do
that
um the second point that I think is
really interesting from that study is is
much more of an implication
um so we looked at the size of teams
that people perceive and their
experience and work quality
and what we found was people who
perceived more other people that they
worked with day in and day out they had
better Care Quality they were delivering
Better Care Quality day in and day out
but if you looked at what it was like
for them the people who were doing the
most collaborating
for them it got better to a point and
then it actually turns negative meaning
for those people that are doing the hard
work to do teaming as much as they can
it's helping them deliver the do the job
but it's in some way exhausting for them
or maybe even ironically like lonely
right you spend so much time teaming up
with other people and at the end of the
day you feel alone in it and in the
Practical implication there is that
for teeming well people need tools and
resources to actually do it well so that
it doesn't burn them out and we know
there's this huge epidemic of burnout
right now and if we don't do better at
helping people manage this complex
teaming environment it's a disservice to
them um and so I think that that uh
paper is really a Clarion call to to do
better in helping people team up well
and for me at least I think part of the
impetus for doing a course like this to
actually try to put some tools and and
perspectives in people's pockets to make
it better
thank you Michaela and all of you on the
call I recommend that you check out this
paper it's called the ambiguity of we in
social science and medicine it is a
great paper my plug for Michaela
um perhaps another way that Healthcare
differs from other Industries is our
ability to fail and learn from failure
and Amy this is the topic of your latest
book the right kind of wrong the science
of failing well where you explore how we
fail productively in healthcare and
outside of healthcare so in a field
where failure can lead to life-altering
consequences life or death how can we
differentiate between good and bad
failures in such a setting
thanks Derek you know you might you
might think I'm stretching it but I
actually do see a really nice segue from
Michaela's and I agree just totally
creative and and fascinating paper
because I think the people who were who
would report greater numbers of you know
team teammates were more probably you
know inherently more aware of their
interdependence
um which is exhausting but it is also
such an important attribute for
preventing the kinds of failures that
didn't have to happen you know when
you're a natural systems thinker when
you're when you're just seeing a little
farther beyond your immediate task
you're going to be more better
positioned to prevent failure so you
know the the key here I mean I want to
just make absolutely crystal clear to
everybody that I would never advocate
for failures where success was a
realistic you know feasible option in
other words let's get success in all
those instances where it's possible
where we know how where we have a where
we have a formula or best practices
let's use them I'll come back to that
but
um the good kind of failure the right
kind of wrong if you will and I call
these intelligent failures are those
that take place in new territory in
pursuit of a valued goal informed by a
hypothesis in other words you have a
reasonable
belief that it could work and they are
and this is really important especially
in healthcare as small and safe as
possible to allow the learning so they
are literally the source of new
knowledge and in every field from
science to sports
intelligent failures are where progress
comes from and strictly speaking
intelligent failures you might be
thinking of them as just the sort of
undesired results of an experiment and
you'd be right intelligent failures are
not preventable right they can't be
prevented because nobody yet knows what
will work you know so so so they are
good but we don't do them you know while
we're flying the plane we do them in the
simulator in healthcare same thing
simulation is a great is a great place
or laboratory science a great place to
advance knowledge through intelligent
failures now the bad failures I think of
them as in two categories one is the
um this the single cause failures that
are generally caused by human error and
and and those of course in health care
especially we want to minimize those to
essentially zero we want to work really
hard not to prevent human error because
that will always be with us but to
prevent and interrupt the error before
it causes a failure here there's also
and you all know this well the the
multi-causal failures which I call
complex failures these are what uh James
reason would um uh describe as the Swiss
cheese of failures there where a number
of factors come together just the wrong
way at just the wrong time and lead to a
mishap in relatively familiar territory
both types basic failures and complex
failures are preventable with vigilance
with teamwork you know with with
psychological safety and speaking up and
of course as much error proofing as
possible including such things as
consistent and highly visible labeling
for medications and all the rest
but all kinds of failure the intelligent
and the and the basic and the complex
can and must be learned from and that
again is where where progress comes from
and I think an essential strategy as I
said for for Effective learning from
failure in healthcare is the use of
simulation you know to practice new
tasks to practice teamwork even and
other any challenging activity it's
better to do it in a very safe place
where no one can get hurt first and and
um just as they do in aviation when the
stakes are of course um so very high
wonderful now let's turn to some
questions from the audience our first
question is from Patrice and Sarah and
they ask with the rise of telemedicine
how do you continue to encourage
teamwork and engagement in a remote
setting and Amy I know this was the
topic of a recent interview maybe that
you gave could you maybe start us off on
this question
yeah you know I first of all I I do
think I think it's a wonderful question
and I think it's a um it's a work in
progress I think we're We are continuing
to learn
um what works
um and but my my
um my starting point is to is to make it
explicit that it's relatively new
territory or quasi-new territory and so
in invite people
um you know and invite people to help
co-create what is going to work and
um engage people explicitly and
deliberately to to make sure
um that we are hearing from the the
different perspectives that we need to
make progress make people make sure
people are are engaged and the team is
getting the benefit of of the expertise
that's present
yeah I'll add one one piece to that
because I I do agree this is rapidly
evolving right there is no Playbook that
we know exactly how to do this one right
yes
um but I I I think one of the areas that
really matters here in terms of teamwork
when you have providers working remotely
and spending most of their days remote
is that this this issue of
sharing information and doing the
behaviors of teamwork that we'll talk a
lot about in this course of
psychological safety during problem
solving these behaviors that we have
been studying and no matter in team
contexts
um I I suspect are more challenging to
get right when it's fully mediated by an
online environment and it requires being
even more deliberates about asking
people to helping people to speak up
asking questions because you just can't
assume you don't know if you're having a
hard conversation with somebody and
their camera goes off you don't know if
it's because they're kids as often
happens to me are running around in the
background or if you've said something
that really upsets them right you don't
know the reasons behind why people are
doing things and feeling things in the
way that we often Intuit better in a
room and so the bar is a lot higher for
getting the interpersonal teamwork stuff
right I think we will have to be even
more expert in this in this online
yeah that's a great Point our next
question is can you speak to the impact
of patient safety incidents and medical
errors on psychological safety and
teaming
door I'd love to start on that one
um it's okay and
um the first um the first thing I think
is really important to understand is
that
um it's not a um just a direct cause
effect you know uh incident impact on
psychological safety it's entirely
determined by how the incident is
handled managed talked about framed uh
by especially by people in positions of
leadership or authority and and and and
um this is just so important because our
the way we understand the events in in
our lives including our work lives is
very much mediated by the frames that
that those in our surrounding and
especially those with power bring to the
incident so if an incident happens and
and it is framed as obviously upsetting
um and um and and and important for us
to quickly learn as much as can happen
and we step back and we do the whole
um multi-perspective
um diagnosis to understand that
all-important question which is what
happened not who did it you know not who
screwed up or what went wrong but what
happened and more often than not that
multi-causal
multi-perspective process learning
process is is very productive and very
insightful for people right they learn
something from it that is entirely about
how do we prevent this from ever
happening again right so a short way to
say this I suppose is when it is framed
as a very
upsetting but Rich opportunity for
learning than psychological Safety Not
only doesn't get reduced it grows
because we're doing the hard work of
learning despite
the the sadness and frustration of of an
incident happening
our next question is from Jeremy and
it's one that I know has caught my
attention recently and he writes uh
Healthcare maybe one of the only
industries that does not integrate r d
into new knowledge the place where small
safe errors can be studied even more
safely within a system to allow for
system learning
um how do we integrate This research and
development mindset into Healthcare with
teaming as a component of the major
function
Michaela I think that sort of sounds
like joint problem solving orientation
but maybe I'm overstating it
so I think at its core right this is a
question about
Innovation and learning
how how do we actually do it when we
know that you have to do both the big
learning right like capital L learning r
d and you have to do the little learning
which is the micro quality improvement
work process improvement work that
um you know people like that Institute
for healthcare Improvement have made so
famous and so accessible
um and and so Amy you bring up joint
problem solving right as a way like a
way to to do this
um because whenever we want to be able
to innovate to make new things happen
whether it's the small learning or the
large learning it's going to rely on
bringing people together from different
areas of the organization different
expertise areas to do it
um and so one of the one of the
challenges when we put together these
Improvement processes
um whether it's r d or or a sort of
quality improvement is
um uh we can get we can get we can
reinforce silos instead of breaking them
down and how we set up the problem
solving
um so one I can give you an example just
really briefly it comes from a case I
just wrote with an old friend of mine
from when I was in grad school and he's
a physician he's an ed physician now in
California and he uh he works at the
Zuckerberg hospital and we wrote this
case because in part in the Zuckerberg
hospital is is named after one of the
most famous Tech entrepreneurs in the
world
um and yet at that hospital they like
many hospitals in America were still
using pagers to page people
um and he led uh an effort with some of
his fellow Ed Physicians to stop using
pagers and to use a smart device
um and it failed and one of the reasons
why it failed when they put the
improvement process together they kept
it all within the Ed and so they solved
it for the Ed but the Consulting
Physicians that they had to rely on to
use that didn't want to use it and they
didn't team up to do it and so I part of
this is not just about the process for
for improvement or even the r d process
but how do we bring the right people to
bear in the right way so that they can
do it together so that the solution will
work in this kind of complex system
so Jeremy your question is near and dear
to my heart I think it's it's high time
that these worlds are kind of systems
thinking teaming and Innovation all come
together more meaningfully
I
completely agree and I hope it's
something that we will learn more about
in the coming years so let's move on now
we've talked extensively about the
challenges that we Face teaming
um in healthcare to what can we do about
them and to do that we'll turn to a
concrete example of teaming in
healthcare that's featured in our course
Michaela you've studied the Cleveland
Clinic could you tell us a little bit
about the hospital and the teamwork
challenges it faces
hmm
so the Cleveland Clinic is a premier
Global Healthcare delivery organization
with an increasingly Global Footprints
um they are expanding and like much of
the activity that we see at least in the
United States uh consolidating quickly
um and growing both vertically with
incorporating new types of providers and
horizontally and spreading into new
geographies
um and they are famous for pioneering
the group-based model of care initially
about a hundred years ago now and they
have ever since then taken teamwork
really seriously everyone in their top
leadership will talk about it
um and talk about what they're doing
about it
and so that makes it a really
fascinating place to learn from when we
think about making teamwork happen in
healthcare because we know these really
large complex complex organizations are
the wave of the future right this is how
a lot of healthcare is going to get
delivered
um and it's one thing to make teamwork
happen if you're running say a small
practice or an organization with 10
people if you're like the Cleveland
Clinic and you have I think there are
over 70 000 employees globally now how
do you make teamwork happen in that
environment is really one of the biggest
questions that Healthcare delivery
organizations face so so we have been
learning actively from the Cleveland
Clinic about how do they manage it and
how did they think about it
and in your time at Cleveland Clinic
you've had the opportunity to speak with
the CEO Tom maholovic and chief
caregiver officer Kelly Hancock about
teaming and they describe a strategy
that they use called the tiered daily
huddles
let's take a look at a quick video
dear daily huddles an instrument for 22
000 caregivers that participate in a
care patients equivalent every single
day
to focus on what matters most for their
patients and to solve the problems that
they can solve
at their local levels and for problems
that they cannot solve on the local
level they can be elevated all the way
up to the executive team so they can be
addressed right that very day
and just to describe it briefly
caregiver teams go through a structured
15 minutes meeting where they speak
about quality safety experience of care
that they're providing expectations for
that day and environment of care in
which they work and any issues that are
associated with any of those aspects
okay that they provide
so the first tier is really every
morning at 7 30 whether it's a nursing
unit or it's at a clinic or in an or
wherever the business is taking place
and then you manage that information up
you manage it up through the six tiers
which the sixth tier is 11 o'clock every
day with the entire executive team
including our CEO and it's amazing in a
matter of 15 minutes a report is
generated about did we have a near Miss
dear we have a serious safety event that
needs to be examined further did we harm
a patient
we conclude the tier VI huddle every day
by remembering those patients that we
served who expired in the last 24 hours
and we do a pause so at the very end
whoever is reporting out will say in the
last 24 hours we remember 25 patients
who expired under our care and they just
name their their first names and at the
conclusion of that as an executive team
we pause for a moment and remember those
patients because it keeps us grounded in
our work
um and that to me that's very powerful
Michaela in this video we get a glimpse
into the tiered daily huddle and one
facet of the daily funnel is something
that you have studied extensively called
the joint problem solving orientation
can you tell us what that is and
describe a little bit of the research
that you've done about it
sure so and I'll explain during problem
solving first and I'll I'll touch it on
um why what Cleveland Clinic is doing
with those tiered huddles is such an
interesting and important way of of
going about joint problem solving
orientation
um so so during problem solving
orientation it's it's essentially about
how much of a we mindset
there is on teams when problems arise so
does a team member see other team
members
uh their own problems as shared across
them
when an issue comes up do they actually
try to work together to do something
about it or is it kind of more I've got
my issues you've got your issues and
maybe we negotiated a little bit but you
are on your own at the end of the day
essentially do they win and lose and
learn together right that is what the
joint problem solving orientation is
really about and it it may seem obvious
but in this case obvious is good right
because it means that it reflects
something that is a really true part
about what it is like to try to make
progress in these environments where
teamwork is messy and fluid and you're
bringing people together across
different different backgrounds to try
to do it and you might not have control
for example over whether
um you know Sue and Bob actually show up
to your meeting they could just stop
showing up in those environments this
kind of shared responsibility for
problems and for co-creating Solutions
is important and it gives people
something that they can do in these
environments to try to make it better
you can try to establish different
problem solving orientation actively and
and that's what I was so interested in
the the tiered huddles for Cleveland
Clinic
um why it really caught my attention
because
um
that daily huddle process yes it's about
identifying the problems that haven't
been yet resolved and yes it's about uh
ensuring that they have their eye on
important issues but it's also about
creating an environment where that kind
of joint problem solving orientation is
emphasized appreciated and prioritized
about how work is going to get done
because you may be in a floor in a
hospital say in Florida and you know
that if you have an issue in the morning
that is not resolvable by you
it if it continues to not get resolved
it will wind up on the desk of the CEO
and that and they are going to sit and
try to solve it with you and so in that
respect it's an interesting example of
the role of leadership in establishing
something like joint problem solving
orientation and then we've studied it
across teams within the Cleveland Clinic
and what we find is that
um for the teams that are able to
instill that more so it's about that top
level leadership establishing it but
even at the department level where
you're seeing departments where people
are able to establish this more strongly
the performance in that department
tends to be higher so it's this
cascading of values around shared
emphasis on problems and shared emphasis
on solving to them together that you can
even in this really massive
organizations
um try to distribute throughout the
entire organization I think they would
say it's still a journey for them
um from 100 years ago with a group-based
care model to today
um but but it's an example of working
hard on it and taking it seriously
Amy you've spoken before about the
hardware and software of teaming and
joint problem solving orientation is
part of that software that you talk
about could you expand on how we can
think about the tiered daily huddle in
those terms of the hardware and software
of teaming sure so I love I think of the
um tiered daily huddle as a as a
scaffolding for teaming and learning
right it's it's in a way it's it's the
hard the the the the the structure right
the scheduled structure of it this
tiered structure is a kind of Hardware
it's it's baked in to the system this is
what you will do right you will do this
from 7 15 to 7 30 and someone else will
be doing it from 7 30 to uh to to 7 45
and you know within a pretty short time
all of the important learning of the day
or yesterday has gotten all the way to
the executive leadership team right
which is a pretty interesting design
um for ensuring that the organization
keeps learning from its own experiences
and does that through teaming right does
that through sharing
um what we know that's relevant quickly
efficiently right you get you get the
you get the um quick impression and
you'd be right that this is efficient
right it's a kind of an efficient uh
structure the software is yes joint
problem solving orientation which is a
mindset that we share this we own it we
co-produce the solutions that work
another absolutely vital aspect of this
of the software is psychological safety
I Define psychological safety uh as a a
shared belief uh that my team is safe
for interpersonal risks like admitting
an error you know speaking up with a
question when you don't know how to do
something
um offering a dissenting point of view
all of those inherently risky
interpersonal behaviors feel more
feasible in a psychologically safe
environment and and so that's a crucial
part of the software of effective
teaming where the the quality of the
data the quality of the conversation is
high it still can be very efficient
um but it's oriented toward learning
you have just a few minutes left before
we get to our next question and answer
portion so I have two more questions for
Rapid Fire one for each of you Michaela
um if there's a theme that has become
apparent in our conversation over the
last
37 minutes it's that teaming just
doesn't happen on its own
um can you tell us a little bit about
what we need to know about leading
teamwork in healthcare
well it's funny and that and it
in the way we've been talking that
timing does happen timing is going to
happen it's all around us right
um whether we like it or not and I and I
think what that what you're saying which
is absolutely dead on is
um that if we leave teaming to chance
and how we do it we will likely be
disappointed
um I often ask in when I when I teach in
person I ask people how many teams are
you on
and people start tossing out numbers and
Healthcare people will say anything like
one five I'll actually I almost
never get one five ten and usually
somebody kind of like throws up their
hands and says oh gosh don't even get me
started and of course that's it's like a
second interest then we get started and
I I love to ask them to actually um
sometimes I have them uh draw it out I
say take out a white piece of paper and
draw it out in front of you what does
your teamwork look like and people make
these kind of spaghetti soup diagrams of
what their teamwork looks like one day I
think I'll put them in like a an art
installation somewhere they're they're a
great representation of just how messy
and really also how much great work is
being going on because all of that
teaming it's a headache to manage but
it's getting something done that's
really important and so I think in terms
of what matters for leading teamwork the
first one the first thing that really
matters is about is about
taking that messy environment seriously
and not wishing it away and just hoping
you know taking your org chart that has
these clean boxes and lines and
hierarchies and pretending like that's
all that's going on
um so leading teamwork is about really
in a teeming environment is about taking
it seriously and starting to learn about
how you can do it better and to learn
not just alone about teaming right but
together with the people that you're
teaming up with how can we do this
better I like to talk about for those
Healthcare Improvement people out there
I like to talk about it I started
starting to think pdsa style plan do
study act style but for teamwork right
making micro level improvements seeing
can we change this and they get better
so that's the first one
learning about teamwork and then the
second one the second real piece to
think about is that teaming and leading
teaming in this environment with those
messy diagrams that people draw out
it's everybody's job
the days where we could kind of hope
that our boss establishes it and then
wait for it to happen are really gone
um it matters what top level leadership
are doing but it's also for all people
that are engaging in teaming it's about
leadership as the set of behaviors that
you do that can make teaming really
Thrive and that means that this is
really for everybody to be thinking
about from day one
Amy last question for you all of these
efforts
um toward teaming require an investment
of time of energy of money perhaps what
are the outcomes of teaming that make
all this investment worth it
ah the outcomes well to me it's it's um
it's it's it's
twofold right one is the quality of the
care or the quality of the work the
quality of the Innovation it's a
teamings outputs are what really matter
you have integrated diverse perspectives
into a product or service that adds
value and
yet there's this dividend right the
other absolutely crucial outcome is your
own and your team's learning I like to
say
um you go to school every day in the
team the team is
um both both the unit of the work but it
is also the source and the context of
your learning so a good day at work is
one in which you've felt you you and
your team did good work but you also
came away just a little bit wiser a
little bit more knowledgeable you know a
little bit more able uh to contribute
um in in the future
so we'll turn to questions now
um I love this first one as I interact
with a fair share of medical students uh
myself the question is as medical
students how can we have effective
teamwork despite the hierarchical
relationships we have in our groups
so can I take that one yes no you know
to me um hierarchy is not the problem
it's how hierarchy is handled that
really matters and
um I I did one um study with the amazing
Ingrid nemheart a former student and
colleague and
um we showed that teams with identical
hierarchy on paper had very very
different outcomes essentially based on
the degree of psychological safety in
the team's hierarchy didn't go away but
the way people interacted with hierarchy
really mattered
um ultimately the aspect of how
hierarchy matters that matters is when
people who show up you know great
clinicians do this spontaneously really
but they show up with curiosity they
make explicit the invitation that they
need and want to hear from others they
listen to what they're hearing they
teach they engage right so higher
hierarchy can be a fine organizing
principle um it's only the way when
hierarchy is sort of badly used that
people
um are less able to engage in effective
teaming
and I'll add to that it's spot on and uh
this uh paper that Amy was mentioning
that with Ingrid Ingrid and emerald
about psychological safety and hierarchy
in teams it was one of the papers that
really caught my interest in getting
into this area
um for thinking differently about how
how we can work in healthcare to
generate more psychological safety when
the hierarchy is not likely to ever
disappear entirely and for good reasons
right there expertise and experience
that really matters here
um and one of one of the one of the
questions that we get asked then a lot
is well
if I'm a medical student and the people
who are higher in the hierarchy than I
am are not creating these conditions of
curiosity what do I do and in some ways
there are aspects if the people if
you're working in a department say and
the chair is not doing it you don't have
control of that over that as a medical
student but the reality is when we look
closely at Healthcare environments it's
not that there is this one hierarchy
that everybody sticks to and it never
changes throughout the day
in the course of all of our days where
we are in the hierarchy often shifts
depending on the interaction that we're
having right if I even for me I can
start out my morning and go into a
meeting and I am the boss in that
meeting and then the next hour I am
sitting in a meeting and I am the lowest
person in the room by far
um and and so for you for everybody
paying attention to that and not not
just carrying the same approach right
not all not always just waiting for
somebody else to create it but to
recognize as we're walking in a room
when we have an opportunity to try to
make a place safe for somebody else to
speak up we have that opportunity and we
can take it and those small
opportunities really matter you don't
have to wait 10 years or 20 years until
you're the chair of your department to
do it you can start now in these small
ways and they can really matter
yeah both of you spot on
um we are almost out of time
um so I want to open the floor to both
of you and ask if you have any final
thoughts that you want to share before
we wrap up today's webinar
but let me quick let me just share what
where Michaela started um which is that
um we are really excited about the power
and the potential of effective teaming
and effective leadership to really
change the game in this important and
hard work of this industry space so we
really do believe
mastering these skills and learning how
to shape the culture and the climate is
Mission critical to your ultimate
success and and probably even joy in
this amazingly meaningful industry
context
and and I would thank all of you for
taking the time today to to join us for
this uh I imagine that not a single one
of you on this webinar today has the
actual time to invest in in sitting uh
through a session like this so we know
that
um this takes time and effort and skill
and that's really one of the most
important things to starting to
establish teaming so thank you for for
taking the time and taking this
seriously it matters it really does
hmm
well thank you Amy and Michaela for
sharing your thoughts with us and thank
to all of you in the audience for your
questions you tried to answer as many as
we could but we hope that you'll take
some of the advice that we offer today
and implement it in your own teams and
organizations as you go back to what you
are doing today but if today wasn't
enough and if you want to learn more we
invite you to apply to be part of the
first cohort of Amy and Michaela's
latest Harvard online course titled
Innovations in teamwork for healthcare
if you apply by September 11th and we
encourage you to invite all of your
teammates as the strategies in this
course work best when implemented across
teams and organizations if you
registered for an attended today's
presentation you'll receive a discount
code for the course in your inbox in the
next few days or alternatively you can
find the discount code and Link in the
chat before we go be sure to check out
Amy's new book the right kind of wrongs
well which hits shelves next Tuesday
September 5th and it's available for
pre-order I know I have my copy on
pre-order and also be on the lookout for
Michaela's latest research on how teams
with steep hierarchies can encourage
more Dynamic contributions from all
their members once again thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you in the
course goodbye for now and have a great
evening
thank you
goodbye everyone thank you for joining
and we look forward to seeing you soon